alert the structure known as the tower
has opened its gate let's check it out
huh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
oh hello hi Gail how are you doing
pretty swell great I am upgrading chips
you sure are this is near automata and
it's the first DLC Miguel what's the
name of this DLC hope I get this right 3
C 3 C 1 D 1 1 9 4 4 0 9 27 I don't even
know if that's right or not but that
sounded pretty good based on your
confident it's very nice uh yeah my name
is Rob this is Miguel we are looking at
V is the first DLC for Nier automata yes
but right now I am making sure my ships
are optimized for these battles this is
this menu should be pretty familiar to
folks who have beaten near automata uh
yes and speaking of which if you have
not beaten near uh this is going to be
pretty spoiler heavy um you said I
believe you said that you you need to
beat the game four times in order to get
to this Coliseum and other content for
the DLC that's what I've been told
ok uh yeah I uh I really like this game
I have not be in it so I'm just gonna
bottle it up and indulge in the spoilers
um yeah like this character I am NOT no
don't know this is yet I think I'm like
I think I talked to you I'm on like the
one of the last bosses I think I've one
more after that anyways thanks for
joining us we're looking at this DLC and
wow this is really different uh what is
your pod that is a is that like a minyan
pod uh it is called the amaz arash of
course head wow that's pretty cool it
looks at you as if it thinks it deserves
to live cool well yeah we're gonna I
believe that there are quests associated
with unlocking some of these outfits I
believe there are some masks is that
correct there's like a few massive think
lever so my girls going to walk us
through that so it looks like oh so
these cyclists syquest coming in and
your inbox looks like
yeah so the first step after you
download the DLC is check your mail
check your mail if you guys have any
questions I'm looking at YouTube and
twitch chat so yeah if you got questions
mainly directed toward Niguel as he is
beaten how many times have you beaten
this game lifetime five times and of
course you reviewed it game in nine nine
ten you you liked this game and I have
been doing it myself yeah I I really
like your mentioning like the menu
it's so cool to like have that
integration where you actually feel like
it like an Android right like look like
even just changing the settings is like
kind of all like tied in with the
narrative right and it's it's fun yeah
there's a lot of fourth wall breaking
stuff it reminded me a lot of Metal Gear
Solid 2 has a big old pig so what are we
off to now you're going to want to
Coliseum's okay this one is in the
desert the desert after you read the
mail you'll get the coordinates for all
three coliseums
yeah goop says uh I mentioned that I am
NOT being this game yeah I guess I'm not
near the end I'm at I'm at a point in
the main or first story where you're
battling this like giant worm in the
ocean and he was pretty unforgiving
those like I think I was telling you
like I think I had to put it down
because I was playing like all day but
could not beat him and the auto-saves
are not very forgiving so I kept like
replaying like the last stretch of the
boss fight I believe but yeah I guess
I'm not very close to the end turns out
because I have not seen her that's what
my pointless what's her name
a - a - oh so this is it
we are playing on ps4 an epic runner you
are not late at all you are right on
time
six trials all right let's do this
really just leave trial of sand okay
cannot use items uh-oh that sounds like
a trial all right so no items no pod
sheer melee
and nice how many times have you
upgraded this weapon just like the wool
uh yeah I like shemin's just a vicious
vicious sword or something
see actually it's been a while if I'm
distracting you and utilize your good
virtuous treaty Adeline I've been
upgrading level three that's where I'm
at pushy next whoa
little helicopter
what kind of a penalty I'll get if I
actually try to use my power
ryuk ETSU says three challenges sorry
three challenge arenas for each of the
characters looks like this is the first
nice
mm-hmm
oh hell yeah
you're playing on normal mode right
mm-hmm yeah all right
it's kind of easy if I do say so myself
so far yeah for the record I am at level
47 47 and you were telling me that there
is a Coliseum fight it's just with the
the one with the devs the kind of famous
one I don't know um one of I mean I
think I guess two of the three will have
the doves mmm and I think you're saying
that that is supposedly level 80 is the
requires but I think there might even be
level 99 Oh God
battles 35 all right Oh oh dang so you
do you get your pod now I hope so
oh my gosh we even sprint yeah so that's
Fred
but it's probably hard to use right it's
the same but you're right
how many pods do you have then you get
up to install can I hold I don't know
yeah I have to as well if you find out
one in the desert right
Hey
uh-oh
I have not seen those guys before oh
wait maybe bad
giant spinning saws built like fun Oh
there's only three pots I assume poop
says there's three pods yeah I guess
there's one where you find I guess it's
just random as far as like like a
sidequest right
oh yeah
Shh we've got this mm-hmm
is there any kind of story behind this
pod you got there this or the mask of it
no well I think probably like near or
Drakengard
fans could probably share and paws it
and look at the first game by you cats
who says challenge for pain in the ass I
hate I hate these guys
okay don't they speed up everyone you
kill I believe so
three minutes eh oh I hate these dudes
oh you fish the third pot out of the
water somewhere
drowned City I don't think oh I just got
there oh and I can't use items these
items you know I think that that
requirement applies to all the plates
here oh that's fun
you got this
oh god I suck oh [ __ ]
sure let's go
Oh see what so you okay so you probably
would want to put on a chip that has
like a health regen or something right
that one form exact right that would be
pretty key for something like this but
you're doing it dude nice
nice
yep give auto-fire hunters issues I'm
just holding to not letting go I'm just
holding our one there sure what are you
oh I wonder if he took his NIH's other
buddy didn't take damage on that
come on
oh [ __ ] I wasn't even locked onto the
road alright alright
oh he's making it rain
oh yeah come back
don't see
there's that chip do exactly they add on
like critical hits you get health back
or something or is it just Auto regen I
believe it's Auto region it's overtime
okay
again if you're just joining us we're
taking a look at three c3 c1 deal one
one nine fish it 409 hmm
try again 194 409 nope oh I wasn't
looking at the timer I just realized I
get a timer
thanks I'm giving you a my own trial
that you have to you have to say this
number while you play it don't worry
hahaha 3 c3 ok we'll place our that one
good 3 C 3 C 4 0 9 mm-hmm 27 yeah
now say it again 3 C 3 C 1 D 1 1 9 4 4 0
9 27 it's all about mnemonic devices I
know I remember what 149 but 409 is the
cleaner and 27 is usually when we lose
our rock stars the age
[Music]
Oh
no Gotham I don't know very much about
this game that's why guy Miguel here I'm
just here for the show hey guys you guys
have any questions hit them are away so
I can have Miguel answer them while
fighting
3 C 3 C 1 D 1 1 9 4 4 0 9 27
there you go
yeah
Tinchy Hawk Hawk wing says get some
melee hits in there and then in 30 left
you got this
got a minute to kill these guys hanging
good see
why you cats who says
she has a berserker mode
oh is it a - does automatic
I have no idea I'm not
is a possible Feld guild ask if it's
possible get to port the fourth ending
from chapter selection like can you get
the fourth ending without finishing the
entire game I thought you only get the
chapter select from getting before
ending elf is another wave ah L is they
say L 3 and R 3 together will do it okay
yeah got it good you know what I just
realized those dog these like
four-legged ones they're totally those
Boston Dynamics alright though I feel
like the ones you kick the ones that you
kick and here they are fighting humans
in the future we're not humans but
androids they have they have wrecked the
human civilization do one more
yes apparently if you hold l3 and r3 and
I should be doing it but but apparently
it'll drain your health alright I'm
going to be more aggressive on the
mailing this first round
I got a question for Chad what's the
best odd ability I think I have a few I
could mix it up a bit yeah my next time
the spear one I was using on like some
like minor bosses and they would it
would impale them and stick them and
that could go up and finish or use like
executions I guess sir iron up whatever
you call them like that I QTE like you
lost let's try it again if it if I fail
this next time we'll go to a different
Coliseum wait then be gone wait a dawn
asked work and I find this DLC I believe
it's out you can find it wherever your
desired platform is I I didn't I never
got any of the shields
I didn't most of my like load outs even
as far as like skills I just it's just
all tack and go to our Mirage okay and
let's mix up some how did you use this
bezerk remote I want to see it in action
I want how much health it dreams
try the mmm
that do anything machine mask no that
looks cool
and let us give some fanservice here
with the grimoire weiss that is the book
from the previous near Liz James ask if
there's no Triforce this Thursday what
we're going to do instead we got
something to come in
I think it's Thursday the fourth
Thursday's before isn't it
Thursday is the fort may the fourth yeah
we are actually doing something
Thursday we Peter and I and Luke Michael
Hardy are going to look at all the FMV
for in honor of Star Wars we're going to
look at rebel assault to the FMV for
that come on that's alright
and it's okay and then we're gonna do
also uh the other game dark forces 2 and
those cutscenes are amazing should be a
fun time having not seen that it's a
really bad acting and production so good
all right maybe you need to say the DLC
name again give it to me that's why
that's why they say to me c1 d1 194 409
27 there it is Oh oh yeah
was that that Berserker mode no it's the
Mirage I was asked a lot let's see the
specific room now I want to see it not
look like you think I haven't been
activated l3 and r3 yeah it sticks got
nothing if you hold it
god that's tight
ah
yeah Tenshi Hawk wing uh yes to bees not
on screen I'm on the same boat so yeah
again if you're just joining us
currently you need to beat the game four
times in order to actually see this DLC
in action so spoilers lots of them and
keep your save file there's a you'll
you'll be faced with a decision at the
as you approach the fifth ending and one
will result in the deletion of your safe
okay you said that earlier it didn't
really hit me what it's just like as a
cruel joke no it actually warns you it
tells you what the consequences okay why
just to just I mean that seems like I
would ever want to do that there's
actually there's actually good reason
why you would want okay I guess that
done much okay
spoiler free
fifteen seconds on the wave three
oh if you've completed the campaign with
a to Boston Dynamics Boston Dynamics
still alive
they truly are a reliable pieces of
machine yeah I guess you'd be if usual
is it if you delete it start if you
complete the campaign with a - then
you'll be able to get it oh god this is
the last wave hope so
come on tentacles No
close
oh you're the best you're gonna get
you're getting close good again okay a
challenge can you wear the DLC outfits
in the main game I believe I mean we
have to unlock them right yes what I'm
wearing right now is actually the DLC
okay you can get but you already get in
the PlayStation Store before this
particular deal see right that that
robot head right yeah
and the outfit or no the app is that
well this is a a Tuesday fold oh yeah
it looks like a good road markers for me
to get to the third way with one minute
you need got some tips from
Ryu ketsu who says you need to do
consistent and constant melee damage
because you're hot ain't gonna cut it
says and goof says you probably should
have ranked for weapons he has goob has
ranked for weapons
all right thanks goop
Oh
ciao whoa
denied he was denied every mood
just the last way Internet Boston's 3 C
3 C 1 B 1 104 409 27 just like the
robots mm-hmm yeah 45 seconds you got
this
get more more mail a rock
get in there
yeah yep
[Music]
hell yeah get it nice yeah
way to go nice job dude Thanks and in
heels I like the idea of her putting the
sword in the sand and I just gonna back
her back gube says did he did it did he
did do it how much is this game uh $18 I
believe or the DLC is right yeah and I
believe that the main game is on sale
because there's a PlayStation Network
Golden Week sale Golden Week I like that
for the Japanese holiday hmm that's all
right items and I'm expecting to get my
ass kicked
Oh yup of wig this next round
60o I'm ready yeah
are you ketsu I believe in saying your
name right says now prepare for torch
around four to see me oh man I did not
hahahaha oh god well they've luck on you
can see their eyes there's no time limit
what what what'd I do what'd you do
what'd you do what'd you do good ketsu
well they did I well I was talking over
it I'm really mad a bad what don't get
hit is that it
[Laughter]
you can't get hit once oh come on
maybe Ryu in the jack and confirm that
because that is ridiculous
I mean that seemed to be what happened
right that's so that's you're done all
right
the buzzer hasn't sounded huh what did i
do last time oh did you take it I think
there was um there was sort of this glow
around me all the my pod light look at
what the buttons iPod light oh are you
hitting it by accident I think so is
because that's a it's not a click it's
like a right left click that's pretty
tough because I accidentally hit that on
all the time and just by the sheer
frantic nature of this game I get a
little tense
what's the maybe you can like like heart
I don't know change the control scheme
of it I mean this this design system is
pretty intuitive I just need to pod
light chuckle oh I just don't press art
l-3 I just don't I mean but I do it by
accident maybe you want to like can you
turn it off or something that nope click
it maybe can awaken custom well I mean
oh there you go just do uh you know uh
you try to use items BAM
well this can be that easy will you
accidentally use an item hopefully they
like manually turn that off I'll see
let's give it a shot
no light no problem it's currently on
your likes currently on sale immediately
hopefully it turns up looks like it all
right now you got this wake up my light
on you're gonna fail me right now I know
it's not on it's not it's not on
it's though it's the light from your
weapon
your pod flare oh man Oh Oh [ __ ] all
right oh I was a good that was a good
thing I haven't seen one of those in a
while
oh my god you were about to die don't
die
I was keep my distance haha okey bye
Owen are you done hahahaha dude that
happens I've definitely done that a mile
away you see it covered it was like mmm
deer in the headlight ok I'm changing my
pot weapon to the laser oh is that a
recommendation no I mean I just these
guys are pretty like bullet heavy so or
what about the shield try that I'm not
too familiar with the shield I'm not
either Matt imagine is just like a you
know or the blade is cool right the
blade and the blade won't well you'll
stop some of those balls of energy I
don't even know we call them shield
those orbs
a Z I don't think we have berserk mode
yet have you have you been that you
probably have if you be in the campaign
with a - yes yeah
yeah oh my god
you know I'm using the laser this is
pretty intense
ryu katsu recommends one light weapon
one heavy two heavies are too slow to be
honest
yeah can I got that right oh well yeah
so you got any like horror level weapons
have you up I mean have you upgraded
anyone's here no you can't like me I
like okay like just contract two or
three see sure I like it
Oh Gabriel brings up a good point maybe
you can't use Berserker mode because
it's one of the rules like they removed
it sounds fair
sounds fair to me I do you know this
have you seen this beserker
move at all I'm sure I've used it yeah
I'm seeing I'm kind of curious to see
what it does looks like
Oh taut fell guild says the tot chip
have you ever used that no well I don't
know if you can because the tonk chip
uses a light so maybe wouldn't it
actually wouldn't work that probably
wouldn't work the touch the taunt chip
basically use you taunt your enemies
with the light by flashing in their face
and I believe attack power for both you
and enemies goes up like 200% which is
interesting all right I think I am done
with this calcium oh whoa give it one
more shot okay
you know you didn't do is you didn't
recite the DLCs name dude no no that was
Oh was was James Ezra last death was
liking run over by a Zamboni ways this
list June from the UK I believe so
I'm so a reminder to send me how to
bring over Hobnobs certain free hot
knobs Hobnobs Hobnobs
their british digestives Oh
3 C 3 C 1 B 1 1 9 4 409 and 27 for good
luck yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
don't quit people are saying don't quit
don't give up Miguel I'm right there
with them
try taunting I don't know if that works
we talked about this bold square whole
square e they said I don't know if I
should be giving you this advice with
your fork they're trying to mess with
you oh yeah okay um I just tried to do a
ton right I don't know if I want a
tongue with all these bullets oh is that
a - oh you're just going right under
those things for the most part dude look
at this look at all this improvement
you've made now you're getting a kid
yeah yeah yeah oh yeah
Oh see what Guge is saying that's a kid
what well it doesn't matter because
you're going to beat this right here now
but there's some more tips hot tips
dude look at you oh yeah
man I was hoping that'd be the finisher
the last guy he kind of hard to see in
the dark
Oh in the bag dude
let's just hope there isn't another wave
it's gotta be
yeah yeah yeah oh there's your last guy
what a loser the loner oh yeah more guys
all right
Oh
what
oh man Oh
oh yeah yeah
well does this make you want to play the
game more yeah you know honestly I yeah
I was actually reading uh as I'm doing
the chat people will just kind of remind
me like I really do enjoy this game I'm
definitely gonna finish it I think I
just burned myself out over the weekend
because I played like can't played like
eight hours straight just like that's
pretty good
oh yeah it was good but I got burnout on
one of those bosses I gotta take great
so I was just like doubting myself but
um yeah Feld fields has does a pretty
cool line that I actually really agree
with his like thing about this game he
says your character is so customizable
in the sense that everyone is playing
with the same character as far as you
know the look but everyone's playing a
completely different way and that's so
true like it right when I got I had I
kind of had a hard time I mean to look
like I'd say some of the graphics are a
little dated right but that's fine and
it's totally possible and for me it was
so when I got in the open kind of
overworld I got to the point where
you're able to like fully buy and
customize your skills once I was like
really like yeah I'm catering to like my
own play style that was rubbish it this
is awesome
nice Stoppers yep Oh
you're on a roll
100 rep Oh she'll run run run run run
Fitzy's hot feet
again
that's next come on I have it oh you're
next moon Alice I don't want to scare
you but I have a feeling the next
enemies are going to be my least
favorite and if they are I will be I'll
be sad for you ok but at the moment you
are kicking hey come on ok out of here
that's it one more round
oh really there's there's another thing
there's five rounds ah I was terrified
if it was gonna be those snake flying
ones next oh yeah oh my god there's no
way you could do that in the dark
you said six oxp game again if you're
just joining us we are playing the DLC
for Nier automata what's the name of it
again 3 C 3 C 3 C 1 D 1 1 94 or 409 727
dope what he said alright last trial
pretty good what did you laugh at with
the dialogue the the rule we love
touching the ground oh I need a no I'm
so down I wasn't paying attention
Oh God okay I forget my bearings here
that's gonna be tough what's the worst
lava hot lava oh [ __ ] ah you love it
okay yeah well we'll try this a couple
more times then we'll move on to another
calcium you got this though level 70
what are you again 47 47 this is type of
level I would this type of rule I would
make up yeah
uh-oh you're jumping so much maybe maybe
maybe like get to the other side you
know like maybe like focus on learning
them you know what I mean like get
travel to the other side of the map and
just focus on like not touching the
ground you know I mean and then just
stay there and just like hammer room
with like try you know basically just
what we play betters or just play better
get good
that's right skin yeah I would not be
able to do any of this that's for sure
I'm trying to read Emory I'm readin all
right I'm gonna tease some hush now yeah
if you guys have any questions for
Miguel midlife business and not relying
on my lock-on yes he yeah yeah but I
don't know they're pretty tenacious get
get to the now get to the other side
yeah exactly
exactly following they're pretty good
yeah they're pretty fast aren't they
yeah all right well there goes my idea I
mean I could I could I could cheap my
holy just like keep doing laps and just
regain my health as I'm doing right now
and then lock on and sure fire my laser
and it run away and look how little help
I knocked out okay we're going to
another Coliseum come on you come on
want to do this do it one more we can do
this I know you can chat you agree with
me let's see let's see some
morale-boosting comments for Miguel here
uh-oh so someone mentioned some good
skills let's let's dissect what you got
going on here no offense I mean I don't
mind probably looks like crap let's do
some housekeeping so you got someone
Miguel was saying the I'm sorry gube was
saying the shock uh
we call it the shock shock wave
you have that on the shockwave it's a
it's like a no or yeah is there
shockwave HOD I don't even know if there
was if there is one I don't even know he
said PI but if you go to your your own
skills it's like a shockwave ability I
know he's talking about I have it it's
like um
no you're go to you oh what's that Oh
punching punching gloves you can do it
you can do it get a faster weapon with
the shockwave oh look you're like yeah
I'm saying I think I'm seeing some like
you some more small sword I don't have
to go back to the resistance camp and I
don't know about weapons because I feel
like you're high level weapons are are
kind of key here uh if you go to tak go
like and you got a lot keep going up
drop raid moving speed moving speed
might be nice evade reefs Africa what
resets all about chance of reviving upon
death auto heal which is the resilience
anti chain damaged turn invincible four
seconds I've taken damage the shock pot
is a thing okay yeah it doesn't look
like he has that okay shockwave was what
I think they were the chat was also
mentioning I could try this
invincibility one small swords are great
for air combos which is probably pretty
key here probably probably vino and I
think you got this regardless of melee
defense defense max HP deadly he'll get
good and
I can type this have you I mean I know
what it does but have you ever just
removed the operating system chip yes
it's just immediate death does it does
it do like does it do the ending I don't
know if it ever gonna remember if it
doesn't ending it's too scared to do it
in a while yeah um that's called a loss
a gap you know I want to get a better
auto heal and maybe a better fast
cooldown if I have it
see you later AZ
thanks for joining us if you're joining
us now welcome we're playing the new DLC
for neurons I have a heel for we're on
the last trial here for one the
coliseums and we're gonna we're gonna
crush this trial hopefully we get an
outfit right hopefully
oh yes and if we if shy way oh hello 11
I've got a room I can make room what
would you take out what's that you get
to remove the lemon first I can remove
something if in the unlikely event we
don't unlock the costumes I will unlock
them in my own time and we'll be sure to
have a video up for that nice someone's
going to do it and we're going to do it
here and that's for sure
well this one this specific call seemed
because I'll be I'm really interested to
see what these other like maybe like
side quests they have forget how to
[Music]
clean this up
d orange alligator asks what is the new
dlc exactly it's like what 3 coliseums
three arenas including what the CEO
platinum
oh so three arenas being the Coliseum
one is the Coliseum is that ok alright
anyways tomat oh you think you're good
yeah you can take off some of your HUD
that's not gonna do a whole lot though
you need you don't need save points with
one slot so does it really make a
difference all right I think we're good
let's do it okay unless you got
something else on your mind I'm trying
to make route I forget how - oh you get
back out and you go to uh optimize yeah
Chris plays excuse me and then on the
bottom there optimize was that last
chunk there fast cooldown no it's not no
further down oh that's the M that's the
space I've no that's the empty slot I
thought it was like a white dope let's
fill that up I don't know get better
auto heal OOP
so then what and there's cosmetics which
are tacked on at the end of said arenas
and I think SciQuest as well but I can
also look at I have the passion oh
that's what it might be what am i doing
there so yeah masks with equipped
effects special music for the jukebox I
believe that's in the the resistance
base right right special bullets that
change the appearance appearance OOP
enemy boots oh I was doing this OH
testing our weapons what dude I'm like I
get bad ending in like okay I'm just now
but they're all looking at you maybe
earlier all right get in there show more
you made up you do a quick shock shock
wave - sure okay welcome to it look at
shockwave he is adamant about it
goob is goob is losing his mind in the
chat he wants you to do this biting his
teeth when were you gonna we're gonna
take out them how much 11 I believe or
one of them I saw that plus two little
Welling waves will love and put it up
theirs
I got one check with again you're gonna
make that's Chum room for okay a level
see what can you remove up in a tick
donut jet you can do down attack do it I
can lose down okay it's 10 so optimized
and you think you're good GUP says don't
make me come in there uh what you
outside
come on I know I know you live on the
East Coast
did you look up that you're good yes all
right
get in there
try five you got this hair colors oh is
that what dye is for you're fine you're
fine
ah maybe disengage your ear lock on
camera more often sorry I'm giving you
that's a good mmm like a backseat driver
if you're just joining us we are looking
at Nier automata is dlc automata
automata excuse me
yeah Butthead uh and we're on the last
trial of this arena holy God
well hmm would you take off like defense
or something [ __ ] you I feel like Rex
real quick you're good just do one more
time one more time for you rob yes and
then another five times for the chat
we're so close
I don't even see the effect of the shock
waves turn off your uh your camera yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah look at you give me
some help all right
yeah that's a good tactic see now look
at they're all they're all grouped up
now yeah now get out of there drop again
look at you got this
no I don't thanks for the okay get out
and get out camera off
[Laughter]
I think you have a rhythm gone I think
you should do one more time one more one
more time how are we doing on time
anyway so we're gonna three minutes ago
thanks gamers the gamer
to drill two drills chef oh I like how
he's he's also using the drill as a nice
cat oh it's time to go
ah all right well maybe we should move
on and you can come back with a vengence
later and wreck those BOTS bye moon
lunar have a great day
alright so what's up next let us go
the forest
flooded city will be smarter today he's
got a pretty good point and I keep
forgetting is that you're a level 47
versa level 79 at 16 I know you did but
I mean I mean come on yeah a plus for
effort I agree so sorry I did I
interrupt a war we off to next flooded
city flooded city I just arrived there
in the game it's flooded you feel like
the fast travel comes a little late
like do you get fast travel on your next
playthrough after you beat it sometimes
it's fast travels not too in the grand
scheme of things I mean I mean you can
get this option relatively early in the
game is it yeah I guess it is ah maybe
I've just been playing I've been doing
like ah and this is how I do a most kind
of open-world SciQuest heavy games I
will play and try to complete every
cyclist which is good I guess but I feel
like you level up anyway yeah I just
feel like I'm just like I don't know
missing out the meat of it like I want
to finish the first play did I play the
force area yeah yeah I would have I did
I had to have right in order to fly the
city that's three first that's where you
meet a - right yeah well you meet a two
doesn't she show up sores yes yeah the
castle she didn't she she burgers that
machine baby nice drop down and Heil
Minh let me fix my controls Oh try as
excuse me try berserk mode now because I
want to see it myself
so you hold
no one are oh you know you think you
still have you have to go back in
controls because I think you said to the
light no but you have an item I think
you have item on toggle light still oh
wait no you're on custom mode so turn
turtle type a on my bed yeah there you
go
booyah so B mode is hold l3 earth man
just hold of you rock it look good I'm
holding it down maybe have to get to
battle
what's that red glow you just did
alright right
right
maybe you haven't rocket
it took me a second to realize what I
was who I was looking at Google I
realized that you meet a two in the
forest just giving me a hard time for my
first reaction when I saw you playing
with this character click the sticks
says see pard yeah nothing we doing oh
all right
ok it's just like a buff oh you're all
your health is all you could kill
yourself damn that's cool what the hell
what was that ok hey you got a cool-down
after that berserk your health meter was
like a full top of the screen with a
certain type of item now that's weird
try it again I want to see it again
where'd you guys go so you probably I
guess in order to use that correctly
what you'd want disengage it that's
pretty neat thanks for the reminder
I actually barely played this game after
my review yeah it's full stuff alright
um I need a membership card mmm but
don't run off because you could actually
bribe him oh really did you did you
learn this yes nice thousand G a
thousand does not a lot um Bob Jones
maybe I will regret asking this but I he
says do I know what blue milk is is that
like an is that specific I don't know
what blue milk is yeah we'll probably
regret knowing what that is
with the offensive damage chip you can
heal that damage as long as you keep
attacking there it is really that would
make the mazurka mode makes more sense
Oh blue milk is Star Wars later Ryu
thanks for all the tips wait how does
blue milk how is that related for blue
harvest I have an idea he's but he's a
saying blue milk so I mean that's what
they that's what you know Luke and them
are drinking you see it often oh okay
looking good
alright enough that blue talked milk get
in it
not get by anything
oh people are people watching
yeah looks like you got a little crowd
here they're like four people are
watching we could turn out
Oh
you guys want to stick around later this
afternoon I'll be joining Eric pay for
the neo livestream that's right the neo
lash ring you subscribe to our YouTube
channel I will have the DLC of the
persona 5 Catherine outfits at some
point this week um no this hair look oh
dang alright let's put on some hair if
you want to see well just look at it all
I've got to say we could put on a
specific all guys doing push-ups
so kill him blue hair blue hair for sure
with all that blue talk yeah yeah yeah
Giggy yeah that looks pretty cool
the world may be bland and lacking of
color but your hair does not 3 C 3 C 1 D
1 1 9 4 409 27 I hope you don't wake up
in a cold sweat for setting that stuff
yeah
so
I'm still got some time like 24 minutes
maybe after this trial we go check out
like I'm either there are like our side
quests in the world right opposed to
seeing like another arena if there are I
am not sure how to access them I don't
goo knows how I'm looking at the wrong
yes gamers this game is available on PC
I think someone was saying there's some
PC issues that we're fixed I think I saw
that in the chat earlier quite sure but
this plays great on ps4 for meeting from
most part I had a crash
I had one crash over the weekend just
weird I remember how I'm blacking out
what's the count again you hit so you
have to select it it's a chip okay but
you just flash your yeah no if I clarify
that if you just flash your flight on an
enemy and you'll see them like enrage
and then I believe it's 200% increase in
damage for you and that it's like and
the enemy as well which make it makes it
like you know there's there's a downside
to the taun where I think they can
attack you with more damage as well what
you get choker
now the
triple-check make sure can you wear it
probably wouldn't just be an item right
but did you have those already
yes okay heavy armor have you got yeah
that I don't know if I keep equip it
online this yeah
Kent oh man it's that's new to me this
is a PlayStation 1
let's go hard sound ADA is that new No
like that's something you could probably
wear right the choker I dunno that's an
item you can like sell right yes huh for
for Teck Teck hawk wing says alright
Boston Dynamics says that if you just
hold square she talks
look at all that orb
okay yeah well I guess for to be
[Music]
the flashlight tom is very
if that makes that chip work less time
when you have a to
one of the things in the DLC is also
special bullets that change the
appearance of enemy bullets I would
imagine that's a odd ability right I
know how else you be you be oh good
[Music]
that's her taunt yeah oh that's so cool
Oh do that again thanks for the tip
there or did you really know that I just
blanked out I forgot what this did is
square whole square that's all I want to
get spear dudes are sure sure
all right now you get now you get to do
that time do the time that yeah look at
their heads they're enraged
that time
Boop
I love the Dodge
it's so gratifying
[ __ ] Oh still cool
oh I haven't seen
those stubs they're called studies right
studies but Spears on their spikes on
their shields that's neat
Wow
Oh feetsies
mm-hmm
mm-hm
fine yeah
[Music]
mmm that's all she wrote mm-hmm nice
finish um
taunt up look at that
jeez so much drama I'm gonna fight more
okay rank B there's one more after this
yeah whoa I've not seen those dudes
before the spiders here combined me of
the the doll toy that Syd makes in Toy
Story you know is this baby head on like
the first toy store first toy sorry
that's I'm at first person you haven't
seen the first Toy Story I already went
to her which is funny because I've seen
three you have seen the first Toy Story
no oh my god Miguel there goes my
pop-culture cred I mean now there's only
one everyone's got one movie I'll give
you that one but you need to go home and
watch it right now
you should totally watch it I put them
on them on the grid Toy Story
don't you look at chat everyone that's
right
people are losing it all or just Bob
that's like Mike McCarty saying he he's
never seen a terminator 2 and it becomes
one of those like points of pride where
at this point they were yeah I got some
friends we haven't seen Ferris Bueller's
Day Off and now they've lasted this long
why bother
yeah it's still good I think it still
holds up but yeah I don't know one
totally random thing pop culture related
is that I bought this 1979 book called
nothing lasts forever which was the
source material for die hard
whoa
like as far as like plot yeah and so
most of the characters including al
Powell
Harry Harry Ellis apparently the author
was inspired by towering inferno
how people yeah towering inferno mix
makes sense to me as far as like that
basically is what got hurt is oh [ __ ] Oh
Phil Elliott says he's never had a
friend who watched ET in Jaws that's
those are two jaws is so good all man I
watched ET recently I think was on
Netflix ah that's probably the last time
I ever watched ET man the last time I
saw a tail is like 83 it's it just I
it's very much I think it's children
swim you guys where to go surprise
but jaws on the other hand oh my god
movie is a masterpiece oh yeah the
Indianapolis monologue
oh yeah it's the best there's some
person behind the scenes that guys like
a downside there was something about
that you know like I think he the actor
I will know his name I think he was like
hungover or something you know I think
they all over it I think they all were
like I've been drinking or something
like Pryor that put some character what
they are kind of drunk in the scene the
one thing that I appreciated it like
repeated viewings is when Royce Ryder
says we need a bigger boat
he's actually serious oh is that yeah
there's such such a good trivia and that
I think I think I've seen that because
he actually asks it twice I thought he
was just the initial time he says it is
just such an iconic line I in the back
of my head I always thought you said it
for comedic effect no he is serious
about wanting a bigger boat whoa-ah
people in chat man that's alright I
forgive you but uh Lazo says he's only
seeing jots - man you gotta go it still
holds up
lazar to go see jaws I might I want to
watch it again just talking about it
it's such a good movie
you'll love it it's like every aspect of
it it was funny about watching jaws
right now you watch an opening scene
world of teenagers at the campfire yeah
all those actors are out Social Security
now if you consider when that was filmed
what do you mean they're really old oh
you say mr. H I see yeah that's what I
mean when was a frickin movie I was like
70 80 Porsche that's for this
yeah jaws is gray with some bad hat
harry
or the other really I think my favorite
piece of trivia with jaws was that they
they originally built the animatronic
shark and I think the shot out up north
from here
West Coast like I don't know like
upwards to marina anyways um they built
the shark just put so much money into
way they built it in freshwater and they
didn't account for the salt water from
the ocean and it immediately rested up
or basically broke down and they weren't
able able to use it just one of the
reasons why they further relied on the
technique of like not really ever
showing the shark Foley right which
makes the movie better it's saying I
think and I think that shark is at
Universal Studios I think it's one that
it's like on that tram right I think
they still help because they still
feature Jaws in the tram ride I hope so
I want if they don't you're right like
going there's a kid we gotta freshen up
and there was her act
there was the psycho house
yep yep yep
give me that oh gee jaws
you gotta hate these freaking things how
would you react Rob if you found if
Steven Spielberg
ended up directing a Star Wars movie at
with the current like Disney ownership
I don't know how I would feel
I know he directed like some portion of
Revenge of the Sith Revenge of the Sith
so episode three yeah really clearly he
had some uncredited roles in some of the
book and one of like the lightsaber
battles I know that like you know him
and Lucas are known to be pretty good
friends when he made the first movie new
hope they like you he the first cut I
believe he showed some feet like it was
kind of controversial because I think a
lot of established directors a few of
them didn't like the movie at all and
then I think Spielberg said it like it's
gonna be so I think you told Lucas like
it's this is great
you're gonna we hit gold in so many ways
come on
yeah I kind of agree with Raymond in the
chat he says that he's a little boring
compared to your last trial or series of
trials and the other Coliseum there
hasn't been any restrictions yet at all
where's the life bar it seems like the
this one is this oh you took it off I
think you may have to put that chip out
another way
come on I forget what these guys are
love I was gonna say this is maybe like
I just like an easier series of trials
like meant for like lower-level people
but I don't he's got a level six yes
it's so easy not that subtle but oh wow
get away get away
I'm feeling level 60 now
captain Carter Tron there are other
things yes there are quests outside of
this or these three different arenas and
hopefully we'd get to it we get eight
minutes left
I think sigh I was reading the
description and maybe when in chat knows
it always seems I think you only get the
side quest as a reward after you finish
when these policies I think sounds about
right
because you don't have as you said
earlier you don't have any indication of
where these are you just you just have
your inbox filled with like Karina's
right we'll take a look after this yes
the only thing you get at the start is
an email which gives you the locations
of these arenas
chicken walkers
that guy little light show is Raven it
oh I heard that one of uh David
Fincher's responsibilities in Return of
the Jedi was syncing up the chicken
Walker's to the background really yeah
that's so cool
pa IOM wow that's really cool
how am I still alive
Sonne God I asked if this game is worth
it is it worth getting yes what would
you say as someone who I mean personally
like you know this is very much Japanese
game would you compare it to anything
that would be familiar to big someone
who's not yeah you know I mean at the
risk of taking an easy answer I mean a
lot of the other platinum games and a
lot of studios that had their roots in
Capcom and lot of developers that got
their start gambling you know I think
about Metal Gear Rising revengeance from
a stylistic standpoint and from just the
pacing and just a fast pace of it
reminds me it feels like a spiritual
successor to revengeance and also uh
Bayonetta yeah bein a temperature
and the wait times like light bends with
the sword strokes is very much the first
thing I think of stylistically is
Bayonetta come on
and the other component for me that's
keeping me going is the story is pretty
damned awesome I still have to finish my
first playthrough but it's definitely
one of the driving factors for me I just
really want to see that yeah how it pans
out and affect you having cleared the
first path yeah I know and I'm now I'm
afraid to look at chat with the spoiler
from more hair golden hair light blue it
will be like golden hair sound awesome
alright so can we look at pull your Bob
your inbox
oh well man you have to go to you know
well that quest just is a maybe quest
show up oh this is the letter I get from
the email half-wit inventor knows from
the main game space every trial max
these top two or the quests for for
actually getting to the registration
desk and half-wit and inventor I know
that guy um well my shoe was too golden
here let's see how demanding
a 70 Wow Harry bishops said it well
let's fish yeah poetry he gave Harry
bishop in chat says it interesting says
I did not know that Lucas wasn't
confident on the first Star Wars for
being successful I do know that much
yeah he was like terrified and he worked
with like a DPI like an English dps
pretty established to like it's giving
him a hard time I believe like
throughout the shooting because everyone
you know without special effects in that
movie was like what the hell are we
doing a giant walking teddy bear like
what is this anyone gone off topic but
he says that he said his filbert that
he'd give him 2.5 percent of the profits
for Star Wars
if Spielberg gave him 2.5 percent of the
profits for Close Encounters all right
and Lucas ended up losing about four
million dollars but in the end I'm sure
he's okay
what was that um news report we reported
on recently about how the the writer of
The Witcher took a flat fee instead of
royalties for the game series
that's where he laughs about how he
regrets it foul that he's losing sleep
sure wasn't not there's a couple other
ones I
oh yeah famous royalty deals like or
like Jack Nicholson for his Batman Joker
I think he got he wisely took a world to
cut
I mean royalty percentage
I may be someone else attracting clarify
but I think there's why I remember
hearing again for Star Wars of Lucas
we're like didn't he give said to God
what's this first studios was a
universal did the furthest first Star
Wars I forgot her mouth No paramount
sounds about right
anyways he said to them like if you give
me like what was it like all merchandise
uh royalty and profit I'll give you like
basically all movie and they said okay
it was the craziest thing right like
they of course like I mean Lucas was so
smart Jesus knew exactly what's going to
happen
box has the new hope rights forever it
was Fox
have you seen these videos on YouTube
about the people have been posting their
the super 8 versions of the movies yeah
there's there's such a influx of like
different cuts right with without the
special effects added and the remaster
and Tom who shot first type stuff Rob
how old were you when the special
editions came out I remember well they
first hit theaters right right yeah I
remember going like my dad this is
actually pretty funny stories I wasn't I
mean I was young I was probably like I
don't know maybe like eight and we went
to the theater and they had all three
movies obviously and my dad was like
well I guess he wanted to see have a
show so he won we wanted to see a new
hope obviously being new to Star Wars
he had member him sitting like ah
plumbers all sold out we'll have to go
see Empire Strikes Back then I remember
him like being really bummed that we had
to see Empire Strikes Back as you know
and I'm sure BRE with everyone else that
is probably the best Star Wars hey I
guess it makes sense from a story
standpoint like you want to seem an
order
there was a girl I was going out with at
the time and she fell asleep during
Empire Strikes Back still had a couple
dates after that surprising
I actually legitimately was watching the
Cartwright's last night
Oh fell asleep - nice little bedtime
story
what's the ice-cream makers name again
ice cream maker dude ice cream man
victory the guy who runs around in the
cloud city carrying gay ice cream maker
that they actually wrote like lore for
him he has a name yeah um it's like a
toy they even yeah and like there was
like a whole course at least like a
couple dozen cosplayers
out that dude at celebration just right
and we were just about wrapping up the
stream thank you guys for watching and
see this trial it is the last one of the
Coliseum hear this call a single great
and maybe we'll see some some awesome
rewards hopefully some cyclists will row
hood yes thank you
I'm being cheap here
oh the yields down
what did you say it is like what
appliance is it a blanket I screaming
ice cream maker oh no come on
okay dang well I said that earlier
didn't say that earlier something you'd
say um alright well I say that we call
it and let people experience this on
their own
thanks guys I was intentional we
intentionally failed last trials thank
you guys can take a look at Nier
automata sorry I said right no I didn't
Hamilton automata excuse me
e 3 C 3 C 1 D 1 194 409 27 mmm that's
right
thank you guys for joining us stay tuned
you can spot and subscribe for you got
some gameplay coming up soon of all the
outfits I'm sure and definitely the CEO
bossfights we will definitely put those
up as soon as we get to them nice pose
nice yeah nice all right well thank you
guys so much for watching
Thank You Miguel thank you for joining
us it's New Deal see you guys have a
great rest of the week and I see L see
some of you in the neo stream that's
right if you hang tight
one o'clock we're looking at neo DLC
it's a nice day of DLC with games that
start with M and four letters maybe
we'll do NCIS and narc I love games ok
see you guys